that is what women died from in
childbirth kim kardashian is getting
real about her life-threatening journey
to motherhood I would have gone through
the same pain you know and back for the
result of my having my babies it was all
worth it in a new video for her
shapewear company skims Kim gets candid
about suffering from preeclampsia during
her pregnancies with both North and st.
when I was pregnant with my daughter
North I had a condition called
preeclampsia or toxemia which is
basically when the moms organs start to
shut down the only way to get rid of
that is to deliver the baby just a
little refresher Kim was able to give
birth to her oldest kiddos north and st.
but had to have surrogates carry her
youngest kids Chicago and Saul I hated
being pregnant but I still even in how
much I hated it if I could do it myself
I would have preferred that the reality
star revealed that her daughter North
weighed just four pounds when she was
born and came almost six weeks early
then after giving birth to North Kim had
a life-threatening condition called
placenta accreta
so my placenta grew inside my uterus and
that is what women died from in
childbirth the 39 year old said she
struggled with the same conditions the
second time around with her son st. and
had to have multiple procedures done
after his birth to help her body recover
from the trauma of it all after that I
actually had to have five different
operations within a year and a half to
fix the damage that all of that did from
the inside but on the outside I was
filming and photo shoots and you know
but like Kim said earlier having lived
through all of that she was down to do
it again if I asked my doctors can I do
it one more time and they were like we
won't even put an embryo in you that
would be like malpractice and
opted to have a surrogate to use the
last two different surrogates to use the
last two embryos that we had and in the
end Kim said she had no regrets about
what she put her body through in order
to have her sweet little family I am
just so thankful for my beautiful kids
you know no matter how they came to me
they came to me I'm so thankful for
surrogates Kim opened up to ET in 2017
about using a surrogate I'd admitted
that it wasn't as easy as it looked
anyone that says or thinks it's just the
easy way out is completely wrong I think
it's so much harder to go through it
this way because you're not really in
control and you know obviously you pick
someone that you completely trust and
that you have a really good bond and a
relationship with but it's still knowing
that I was able to carry my first two
babies and not you know my baby now that
is hard for me so it's definitely a
harder experience than I anticipated
just in the control area right that
inner struggle is kind of hard but I'm
just rolling with it and it is what it
is I think it is really inspirational
though because a lot of women have
issues and fertility things going on and
you make things that are not normal
normal and it makes everyone feel a
little bit better about themselves when
they have to go through something like
that so yeah I mean it's I think it's a
definitely a different experience and
I'm blessed that I'm able to do this and
that technology is the way that it is
that we can do this but it's still a
process that you have to really digest
now Kim says that baby psalm has rounded
out her family in a beautiful way and I
feel like having four is so much more
then I feel really calm and Zen I feel
like they all love each other the baby
really like brought back like you know
my two older kids would fight a little
bit and now since the baby's here
everyone gets along
everyone loves each other I'm rolling
with it it's just it is really Zen it
feels really equal and calm and great
and she insists she and hubby Kanye West
are do and II having babies I think this
is it just because I am so busy doing so
many other things I want to make sure
each kid gets so much of my attention I
could I would do even numbers so I could
go to more but I won't
I won't I think that's just like I think
I'll go crazy but I think 4 is the
perfect magic number for me
what a sweet family of course you know
you can count on et to help you keep up
with the Kardashians so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Holly Stephens see you soon
[Music]